hi this is blendin's game ah and you
just totally killed our microphone sorry
I got a little carried away there uh
this is an episode about Seuss's
birthday and why he tried not to block
your face too much what's up Jeff there
we go
uh and why he doesn't like his birthday
hey does it sell Brady doesn't tell
anyone about it just my dad didn't love
me dude
yeah pretty much Susu the the dead uh
during that blending comes back in time
says he wants to challenge the kids to
globnar or whatever it was
sounds like the love song at the end of
return the Jedi could help clever
whatever Club now if if the original
return of July with the shitty you walk
sauce elaborate the go it's so awful
what up I love that sauce you're just
still killing you know Debbie but you I
know um so anywho I feel awful you seem
to remember pretty well I do and I and
in ewokese
in Dory's yeah it translates into
english later where they go celebrate
the love cuz they just do that um
endorsed yes so they so black becomes
back in time challenges the kids because
he ruined their lives ruined his life
so they take the little time device to
go back in time and they find out that
soos his dad never came to visit him he
hasn't seen him in like eight years he
just keeps sending postcards so I guess
whites and then dipper gets blasted by
young Robbie yeah young Robbie it's like
the one flooding Robbie appearance eeeh
bye Robbie that I've liked so far and
rice brilliant I love the fire things
done with the windy dipper romance it's
like oh my god she's laughing it's just
creepy she's like ten years I mean now
you know how she feels haha yeah yeah
Wow um so they decide they're going to
accept London's challenge and have this
great big obviously Tron inspired fight
um and they end up winning as it ends in
laser tag
yes so he's all good Tron style games
should and they travel back and have
they let soos have whatever wish he
wants and he doesn't wish for to see a
father again because it figured he had
his chance so instead he wishes for a
a pizza that infinitely never Stano
first you wish get your guys all fixed
up because spending birthday should be
spending it with people you care about
and he didn't care about me at all
plus I got this infinite pizza yeah the
evidence I was like best idea ever
so um yeah so definitely a sadder
episode but not like oh no it never
feels to fours because you know like
this stuff does happen I mean there are
just some parents that abandon their
kids you know I just know it has to be
solved by time-travel that happens oh
yeah all the time all the time oh so
time cup I know how it is you know by me
it's like should obviously be a part of
their life but doesn't you know
contribute um I wonder if he even like
sends a check or anything like that who
knows he definitely sends the postcards
um so but it but also a lot of really
funny lines a lot of a good seeds I like
now I do I like the Tron references I
like that both the old front and the
neutron because despite if anyone
doesn't like the neutron I get it but
it's like the look of the film is
gorgeous I love the giant time baby and
you must complete this game before the
time maybe drinks this cosmic sand out
of this hourglass come on Owen it's a
note for you come on okay yeah but for
you good for you yeah the fact is
instead of this very loving parents
ounces robotic come on it's good for you
no and then yes I have like this adult
guru no I don't want to it's just you're
worried contradictions going again see
today's episode was brought to you by
the sweater donut which is awesome and
the message in there is don't do the
time crime if you can't do the time tie
so lot we can learn about that no but
actually there are a few things I was
noticing in this episode they're
actually kind of fascinating uh first of
all there's an ad for the for Gideon's
dad some sort of just had a baby sale
yeah
and but the funny thing is somebody
crosses it off replaces baby with demon
and then writes RV was here and I'm
trying to think who does he sell RVs
with I don't think and there maybe he
does but even if it was why was a
Hervey was here so I don't know I mean
maybe it's your RV drugged me does a
thing like he sells RVs but that's me
it's my face my face um you see a lot of
old characters not yet in their own a
you see the tattoo guy without the head
and chin tattoos he's came the tattoos
he only has one I think you see the coat
as a baby still with the weird eyes um
the Sherlock wax statue is actually in
the shop uh when you look there there's
a move Walker poster that's just a fine
throw away gig but okay here's the one I
found the most fascinating and I don't
know if this was all the episodes or
just this one
everybody had in this episode at least
everybody has five fingers except for
dipper and Mabel they have four oh okay
animation wise
that's a weird mistake whoa doesn't like
it doesn't necessarily cost more money
to draw an extra finger but it's one of
those things where it's like you stay on
she you stay on model and that's just a
really odd thing I don't know if it
suddenly happened it's just very earthy
I don't know but now I'm really curious
or is something about character having
six fingers so you got to wonder um but
yeah I never noticed that before it I
know Stan this episode so now go look at
all the other you're the case um we're
running around with six fingers and we
have Mabel and dipper having four babies
someone stole their fingers there extra
four five six I see a pattern the next
one will be seven seven one wouldn't you
like to know uh so yeah it's it's a good
episode a lot lot of good laughs is
definitely very uh uh you know emotional
but not like I still say Mabel just
screaming for death is the funniest
thing I've seen all week yeah a lot good
I love the way they do this future just
everything is very much like how a
little kid would want to see the few it
looks like those laser tag commercials
from the eighties is what it looks like
don't you think ya know yeah you're
right you don't lose your turn doc
usually uh yeah for some reason I just
love everybody standing in line to get
the food in the jail what line is just
upside down and like turns and twins
inch of it yeah cuz I it's the future
you could like the title blendin's game
nice little spoof of Ender's Game yeah
oh yeah try think of anything else I
mean it's nice to you know have a
nemesis ease Zeus get some character
development
yeah and it's it's very fitting and it
just seems like something that probably
what happened to him because he is just
so happy go-lucky about everything like
me one size fits all shirt joke because
so that's just the same shirt he's had
for ten years
yeah probably well there's like a
million up of two that's like the only
shirt they so man also so it kind of
makes sense oh oh yeah I forgot it
disregard me but uh but no it's it's
also keV oh that's where I'm looking for
there's also something inspired about
the phase like even though he's had
this you know source a backstory still
very upbeat and very positive it just
goes with the flow you know what he says
so let's just oh so says yeah I like the
fight he doesn't follow through at the
which you don't even see the father um
so yeah no I like all of that maybe
Walda his father is the author maybe his
father is RV and He will give dipper and
Mabel back their fingers oh I'm gonna
watching the next one to see if they
have four fingers oh we shop Oh
so yeah anything goes you get ya know
that's pretty much it that is so it was
a really solid episode I like the baby
the the baby yeah the time baby is like
just my favorite I it's just so bizarre
and so surreal
I'm always fed that guy who does blend
his voice he's a return character on
adventure time he spent something like
eight episodes if not more of adventure
time I'm always amazed I'm not annoyed
by his voice because it's like I'm like
oh my god I'm gonna get sick of this guy
so faith we can mute him man if only I
knew that earlier but there's something
about the inflections and when he does
and how he does it where it's like it's
always just unexpected enough to get a
laugh out of you the way he says a lot I
am yeah no this is really solid episode
I will say this so a lot of people have
been asking let's let's just settle up
here and a lot of people have been
asking so um yes we will do the shorts
you heard it here first folks without
consulting me he sort of decided this
but it's like I also decided we're gonna
do over the garden wall ya know that
what I really wanted to I I didn't I
don't I didn't consult him on that
so I just did no way then to him down I
just declared on Cameron there's nothing
he can do but I actually could totally
edit this out and you'd never see it but
that's true I've never seen this short
so so I have no idea if they're so even
they either talk about he's decided not
to edit it out because he knows I'm
right
because I'm able and I'm always right
right dipper wait anyway so um yeah the
edit this out